hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to case animatronics now
this is supposedly not a five nights at
freddy's fan game but the comparison
might be made considering what I see
thus far in that it looks like a
computer terminal monitor and there
seems to be an animatronic and it says
animatronic writer in the name of the
game but I will reserve judgment because
that's what I do do not forget to wear
hat Hans game could never mind no
warning for anybody you're going into
this rod and prepare oh looks like I
fell asleep it's almost midnight what is
that what is that range no one else
should be here huh I'll go check I'll go
check I've got a lot of self-entitled
dialog going on here oh good thing I
blurred out all those documents on my
computer time to go check got my
flashlight here let me hold it military
style yes the tablet the department
relies too much on this new monitoring
system at this rate they'll probably
give us a joystick and light saber do
you appreciate my sarcastic sense of
humor it's really gonna help least Oh
probably not a lot if it's given out by
corporate what a comfortable gadget in
ten years these are gonna be everywhere
but still a human is you replaceable I
don't know about that go ahead and have
a look around
probably animatronics are gonna turns up
very quickly you need to save the
batteries energy why am I talking to you
when I was just talking to myself a
little bit ago maybe I'm just a little
confess 'old okay excellent the charger
is in Ben's study what is this I don't
know helps the panel in the control room
according to the evacuation scheme in
the wall on my room the control room is
in b7 well this is a rather bizarre and
disorienting tutorial introduction but
I'm gonna go out there in the [ __ ]
dark holy [ __ ] where am I going what am
i doing why
what was that did you hear that ooh that
ain't good
okay alrighty then hello ah good I'll
turn that off didn't want the light
anyway better this way in the dark by my
own self alone with my thoughts okay
then [ __ ] off okay
oh the stores closed thanks for telling
me that I couldn't looked at it knew
that but you decided give me Bowie hi
why are you covered in blood why you
have such short stubby legs sorry to
insult your height but it happens - hey
it happens to me all the time on the
Internet
were you were you looking at me I think
you was looking at me a little bit okay
wait 1 1 9 I can't read that last letter
1 1 9 7 I bet it is 1 1 97 that a coud
key Kurt huh okay you have fine staying
on the ground forever and not giving up
and shoving your entire self inside me
oh wait hold the other way around
whoa Aon I bet that I meant the stuffing
of the in the suit not Wow okay never
won then holy [ __ ]
alright so I need to find a charger
ignore everything that happened okay
is this Oh what what happened what the
[ __ ] whoa what a terrible troll that was
all part of the plan already time to go
home okay night god I hope nothing
serious okay hello bishop hi marvelous
night isn't it sure as I'm sure you
don't remember me a lot of time has
passed since our last meeting how do you
like the new surveillance system one day
you took everything I had and now it's
time to pay in your apartment there are
some echoes of the past trying to
collect them so you can see who you
really are what a psycho
what happened to the lights is this some
sort of deja vu huh we wouldn't want any
more ones yet the switches in the
control room
oh god not again why do I get the
control room we wouldn't want any sort
of deja vu incident I'm gonna die in
horrible horrible ways it's all gonna be
cat oh hello um alright so why did he
say apartment hello handsome man how are
you doing why did he say apartment when
I'm obviously in a police department
office maybe ooh boy
well that sounded good
is that the same thumpy thump that got
startled me before is that the same a
mannan when to true Mick 3 9 to again is
that a - ok 3 9 2 - let's try it again
same old deal that we did before I guess
3 9 2 - 3 9 - huh key card closed I
don't want to know what that was I'm not
gonna open my goddamn eyes I'm a
steering this pedal like nothing bad
happened in there baby it'll go away 3
fine cuckoo oh I need to find the
electrical panel well how about that hmm
wonder what's gonna happen - here now I
need to turn on the second plate what
the hell is the second plate I don't
know what you're talking about you're
being a lot less descriptive than you
were before
is this the second plate no that's just
the thermostat holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] I
know I can't be too scared about
anything can't show too much emotion I
had my amygdala removed don't mock me I
can't say the word amygdala
I got a lobotomy when I was 12 years old
oh hello hi it's Batman
I should have known there's a grizzled
voice man was Batman
okay alright then gotta find where the
other girls are going
all right so I'm guessing that
animatronio
is gonna be up and walking around now
uh-huh
oh it is mysteriously gone hello well
starting to remember no how do you like
my gift hmm like it like it it loves
love to play play one
okay
well I don't know I [ __ ] expected oh
yeah yeah I didn't think it's gonna open
oops whoops whoopsies I didn't mean that
happen I'm sorry I apologize let's try
that again
oh maybe too intense for pregnant women
well that rules me right out okay let's
try that again
all right okay do this skip the dialogue
we're all right fine this one I guess I
bet this is gonna be good
hmm where's the dialogue that's gonna go
what the hell was that I hope that
thing's not trying to kill me
it was like some sort of animatronic I
probably should hide hello
oh it's right outside the door huh good
it didn't seem to spot me am i free now
okay that's not that's that's a good
sound oh right all right I'll assume
it's gone so we're whoo yeah it's it's
out there
reading that ain't good
where is this other panel oh titty
sprinkles I went the wrong way
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] dicks shitty dicks can i
crouch I can't I'm Bob or knocked oh I
went the wrong way
oh I went the wrong way oh I know what
I'm supposed to do I'm still I'm
supposed to go back through the door
that uh this hey well oh good thing it's
not very smart get the guy I'm the smart
one here can I close this door yes I can
it'll never be able to get through now
I've outwitted it I am the smart okay
what now the hell is another panel Jesus
okay
can't see [ __ ] with stupid flickering
lights I did nothing
well I was pointless god dammit I can't
see [ __ ] I don't need to hide it doesn't
help when you're shining your flashlight
out of that stupid doorway okay
there's got to be like another panel or
something around here somewhere oh
that's convenient huh Hey oh good
there's a giant thing in a giant crate
that's probably helpful for me maybe I
can unleash him just get him to fight
each other I'd be nice hey stop that
that's government property hey my friend
who the Frick are you are you from five
nights at candy's where's this panel
where's the goddamn panel I would have
thought that it would have been in here
I mean it looks exactly like the kind of
place that would have a panel I open
this No well dang it
there ain't no panel in here alright
then carrying on I have a feeling I'm
supposed to find like a keycard
oh good thing I ate [ __ ] man
holy [ __ ] okay well like I said I
imagine I'm supposed to find a keycard
and that's gonna help me get to other
where the hell am I now where am I now
why am i over here oh god damn it
well I guess I didn't get very far okay
so my imagination once again tells me
that there's got to be a keycard around
here somewhere I just gotta find
anything donut's
oh good doughnuts maybe it'll be mad at
me that I eat all of its doughnuts do I
give a [ __ ]
the answer is no hello can you thank you
Halloween is tomorrow no none of Agosta
maybe I'll make one of those hotdogs in
Bedford Suites still that moment at the
exhibit so Hans me I can't believe she
spoke to me all the past by and laughing
at my painting and shouting as I was a
child yeah I thought it would be better
did I write them there but she came by
she stared at my painting until he ADO's
over the animatronic from the family
pizzeria that I visited with my parents
when I was kid very cool that's how I
began to communicate with Emma Oh
interesting
is this the words of the guy on the
phone and and somehow I stole Emma away
from her him is that what I'm supposed
to be led to believe hey you never know
what these things I remember seeing
another note in here somewhere
I don't know randomly generator if it's
all just very very specific layouts
seems to be randomly and eat the
doughnuts don't get mad at me forget the
last one ah there we go
according to the dr. John Bishop tried
to get into the hospital ward of the
injured Scotty recently emerged from a
coma barely clinging to his life as it
hangs by a thread
any trauma can cause heart failure and
permanent damage to the nervous system
right now they much more than stabilize
the victim now not even remember what
happened before said the head doctor of
the university's hospital it was
revealed that John Bishop entered the
warden
and demanded answer from Scot according
to the witnesses John tried to figure it
out what the hell happened on the day of
the crime Sam Scott refused to answer
his questions or even talk to the police
officer according to the doctors when
the guards were finally removing the
police officer from the hospital he
shouted I'll be bak
the hospital is going to soon demand the
dismissal of said police officer ok very
confusing don't a break I always get so
hungry when I'm scared Oh Harold I made
a proposal to Emma I'll remember that
day for the rest of my life the
beginning of a great summer and the
launch of a moving animatronics kit can
even bring pizza to kids I added a
remote-control system for any kind of
emergency in just in case something goes
wrong I found a suit for one of the old
animatronics from the family restaurant
it was a bit rusty but it works and I
even modernized it a bit now the most
important thing is to protect the
children I have a couple ideas but I
think the authorities refuse to
cooperate but it's worth a shot
we began to receive offers from other
organizations that want access to my
schematics for the animatronics but I
declined all requests because I cannot
break the contract ok interesting thing
to write out I'm not sure how that
pertains to me a little more story it
turns out the restaurant was closed
because of a major competitor and there
was a terrible incident there was a
specifically designed suit of
animatronic for a man but they say can
he gave me why I'm reading this you
better not children were very frightened
to see how the suit was brought
squeezing his body the news says he is
still alive I wonder why the suit broke
the new out company has spent a lot of
money on advertising now all the people
will discuss this new pizza place but
their animatronics can't walk at least
any of these characters very cool it
feels like the coolest news in the past
6 month ok I'm about to die damn it
getting this far man I don't even know
if I'm on the right track for getting a
key card I do not think that I am seems
like he left me alone for now but I've
gone through just about every drawer
that's accessible to me because I must
be doing this like some wrong way there
I must not be doing this quite right it
must be something that I'm missing like
all together there's something there's a
piece of the pie
that I'm not putting together whoa hello
wow did not notice the bathrooms why are
the bathrooms here okay where am I on
not not where I need to be close but not
where I need to be oh hello
hi the key card for some door it's a key
curd huh well doors locked with a key
card too bad I only have this key card
okay so as I recall
there were only a select few key card
locked doors one of them hello hi friend
how are you oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
well get in the closet
you never saw me I got a key card I did
not know that it would just be lying on
the ground in locker room I don't know
why I didn't know
it's right there ah shitty tits okay um
so I got the key card that is good
progress but not exactly what I wanted
to do so I'm gonna end this episode here
because I got more to figure out soon
but I got a few pieces of the story and
I got a few spoofs that was actually
terrifying being able to see the thing
standing outside the door that's a nice
touch but five nights at Freddy's fan
game this still is so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
working didn't work on that other guy
answer my question